good morning hank it's friday pete's and
miss rolls on so in early february 2020
i wrote a video script called a feeling
of impending doom i often write videos
that never actually end up getting made
and in this case i'm very grateful the
video didn't get made for reasons that
will become obvious but rereading that
script now it is really interesting to
consider what i knew and what i didn't
know and also what i thought i knew but
didn't know okay so when i am currently
in october of 2021 i will be wearing
this shirt available only during
pizzamas at petesmas.com and when i'm
february of 2020 me i will wear this
hoodie great hoodie by the way good
morning it's tuesday if you google and i
don't recommend doing this by the way do
as i say not as i do but if you google
the symptoms of a heart attack one of
them is a feeling of impending doom like
the medical profession often struggles
with language so i think we should give
credit where credit is due a feeling of
impending doom is just perfectly
evocative but one of the big downsides
of having a serious mental health
disorder is that i often have a feeling
of impending doom and no real way of
knowing whether it's a heart attack or a
panic attack
or you know actual impending doom okay i
was obviously onto something here like i
had a feeling of impending doom in
february of 2020 and that was warranted
then there's this which also holds up
fairly well i'm a big fan of certainty i
think it's so underrated like it is
really nice to be able to wake up in the
morning and plant your feet on the floor
and feel certain that the floor is going
to hold your weight ah
buddy if only you knew but certainty is
also almost always an illusion the more
we grasp for certainty the less we find
it and right now uncertainty is creeping
into my peripheral vision and i'm
beginning to doubt all of these
realities that until recently felt
totally assured oh geez don't you want
to just pinch his cute little cheeks
okay here's where we get to the part of
the video that really does not hold up
like it is very likely that in two
months we'll all be like wow we sure
overreacted to the threat of coronavirus
very likely very likely very likely no
i'm not sure it was ever very likely but
when i'm trying to deal with uncertainty
i tend to look at past personal
experience and i could look back at 2009
and the h1n1 flute which was very
serious and killed over 150 000 people
worldwide but didn't kill millions and i
could look back to sars which was
extremely dangerous but successfully
contained that said by february of 2020
there was a lot of evidence that kovid
was going to be different from either of
those diseases but i tend to look back
at the past to predict the future a
phenomenon that has some big flaws that
i'll get to in a moment but first let's
go to what february 2020 me thought was
the worst case scenario it's also
possible that in two months we'll all be
like coronavirus sure was catastrophic
was catastrophic and two months were
remembered as something that
was catastrophic i mean you knew how
infectious diseases work you study this
stuff you're literally obsessed with it
how did you imagine a worst-case
scenario that was 60 days long but
here's the thing yes we can use the past
to understand the present and to imagine
the future and god knows you can use it
more carefully than i did in that
february 2020 video i thankfully never
made but what the past can't give us
can't ever give us is certainty about
the future or for that matter about the
present and one of the big benefits of
looking at the past is to remind us of
that fact like we can talk all we want
about the 17 causes of world war 1 or
whatever but nobody on earth on january
1st 1914 had any idea what 1918 would
look like and that's one thing that
hasn't changed between february 2020 and
now living amid history demands a
measure of humility because
we don't know i have no idea what the
world will look like 20 months from now
i would say like i can't wait to find
out but i feel like i i i can't wait i
don't mind waiting uh positive ending to
the video
pizzamas is great i mean your number one
source for pizza related meme apparel
continues to be pizzamas.com hank i'll
see you on monday